i just gotta finish dusting off my
collection here i just gotta send one
little email out hold on one second
hey there uh i'm um scooter hey
i'm walter hello i'm miss piggy
and i'm kermit the frog hello i'm pepe
the king prawn
and i am the great gonzo and we are
taking a
buzzfeed quiz to find out which
muppet we are i'm scooter
as far as i know i'm walter this is very
meta
first things first how do you most like
to spend your free time
watching a good movie reading a good
book talking to a good friend
sleeping shopping or doing absolutely
nothing
i never spend my free time you know if
it's free i keep it i guess i would say
reading a good book
i'm uh reading um a book uh lean in and
fall over i've got the lean in part
working on the fall over part i think
shopping because you know i go with
friends and i don't have to bring a
credit card
for me it's a it's talking to a good
friend or better yet you know listening
to a good friend
how about you oh shopping duh free time
work time anytime
for me it's sleeping i have really weird
dreams at least i think their dreams
because
yesterday i woke up and there was a goat
riding a unicycle in my living room so
that
might have might have actually happened
i love watching a good movie
i mean the muppet movie the muppets
muppets most wanted
a great muppet caper muppets take
manhattan terms of endearment you name
it
what which disney princess would you say
matches your personality best
tiana ariel bell rapunzel
snow white or moana snow white because
uh you know
with the muppets i sometimes feel like
i'm surrounded by the seven dwarfs
and they're all grumpy watch it present
company excluded
moana she is fearless
just like i hope to be one day i'd say
ariel but i'm not a strong
swimmer i guess lately rapunzel they've
locked me in a room
in an editing room with no escape i
would say belle
why because she's into beasts what's not
to like about that
okay i say moana why i don't know
for me tiana the princess and the frog
been there done that what word do you
hope
your closest friends use to describe you
incredible well i was going to give you
a choice
oh okay smart loyal cool
funny hard-working or perfection
incredible it's not on the list
i'm gonna go with um with smart yeah you
know it's a it's a glasses thing
they help with um avoiding getting
punched in the face by a
certain pig she aims for the solar
plexus loyal
because i would do anything for my
friends how about you do i even need to
say it
perfection cool yeah cool okay i'm cool
i would pick hard-working nobody does
what i do by accident
takes a lot of hard work to make sure
the accident is perfect
out of that list i'm going to say funny
i'm working closely with fozzie to
master the
art of comedy using his jokes so far
i've only mastered the art of tragedy
you're putting on a talent show with
your pals
what's your talent singing stand
stand-up comedy
dancing magic tricks whistling
or me being there is a talent
uh magic tricks as long as it's a
dangerous trick
i am going to saw myself in half wow i
go see this
duh whistling whistling heck whistling's
what i'm known for
it not not not that i'm known but but
but if i were
known it would be for whistling i can't
whistle
no you cannot i can do all those things
but i think i have to say
me being there is talent enough
sometimes i just stand there and they
applaud
i'm gonna go with the stand up because i
i tell jokes
do you wanna get a job yes okay what did
you get when you cross an elephant with
a rhino
i don't know what do you get when you
cross an elephant with a rhino
and if i know
[Laughter]
uh okay well for me i'm gonna say
singing you know
like this uh why are there so many
okay okay we've heard that song enough
move on okay but mine would probably be
singing well actually beatboxing here
watch
scooter is my name i don't drive a bus
watch me on muppets now
streaming on disney plus
wow i think it needs a little work but
you get the idea
which actor would you want to play you
in a film about yourself
brad pitt aquafina will smith viola
davis
dwayne johnson or margot robbie it goes
without saying brad pitt
that's great choice scooter thank you
brad pitt could you just excuse me just
for a second
just a second of course
ah you okay oh yeah i got something in
my eye okay
i'm gonna go with will smith good choice
i will
with margot robbie for obvious reasons
will smith
the fresh princess the frog prince i
kind of like that
i would say aquafina hands down i mean
look she's she's an actor comedian uh
she she writes she produces she's a
rapper look
if i ever learned how to even do one of
those things
she'd be perfect to play me for me viola
davis
well i mean we're very good friends and
we both have
no wait wait no she's the one with the
oscar i don't have one yet anyways we're
good friends
and friends let friends borrow their
oscars right biona
what are you most likely to be doing at
a party
dancing chatting with friends eating
singing karaoke looking for the exit
or hosting could it be dirt party
yes then i wouldn't go i'm gonna say
dancing
look i'm amazing at it watch
yes
it's better with music of course well
that's easy chatting with friends
yeah it can be loud there at parties and
if someone asks an
awkward question you can pretend you
didn't hear them singing karaoke
and eating kale simultaneously i would
be looking for the uh the nearest exit
i think yeah well yeah you know i've
been to a lot of parties uh with the
muppets and it's always good to know
where the exit is and the location of
the fire extinguisher
hosting because it would be my party i'm
a big
you know party animals okay
yeah for me eating i start with a
dessert cart and work my way backwards
and finally pick a little something to
enjoy on disney plus
the mandalorian hamilton high school
musical the musical the series
diary of a future president encore or
disney's fairy tale weddings
hammer tense because we both speak
spanish and i like
rap opera i'm gonna say disney fairy
tale weddings it's
oh so romantic oh yes
hamilton i adore lin-manuel plus i want
to make sure he's not making any ham
jokes
i'm gonna go with um a high school
musical it's nice to see that um
you know you can put on a show without
uh chickens and penguins and
you know there's other ways to do it for
me it's the show encore
it's about putting on a show and uh you
know that's what i love the best
and i pick the mandalorian because just
between us
when he takes off the helmet i hear he
looks just like me
i got walter hey validation sweet
validation whoa
i got miss vicki i got me i got me
if i was anybody but me i'd be upset
i can't believe i got miss picky and i
got walter
let's see i got um scooter hey
i love that guy i got kermit great
yay breaking news
buzzfeed's which muppet or you quiz is
on point
yeah yeah i learned that from you
scooter
yeah like that yeah it's a little bit
it's like yeah
yeah yeah there you go oh thanks
you